the hiring process is broken if you're
an entrepreneur you're trying to grow
your business building team is gonna be
one of the most important things that
you have to do for your company you
think about it you know right now if you
are sole entrepreneur you're adding all
the value in your business but as you
grow as you build a team as you get more
and more people your role actually
becomes less and less valuable right the
amount that you're contributing to your
company compared to what your team is
contributing goes down your team becomes
everything they become so important so
getting the right people on board makes
a difference and a lot of entrepreneurs
they can't get past even hiring the
first employee you're hiring past five
or hiring past time there's these
barriers that make it hard for them to
give up control and to bring the right
people on board and a big reason is
because the hiring process is broken it
sucks it's time-consuming it rarely
works and you end up with people who
come and then they leave or you're
trying to bring in new people and
there's such a pain in the neck
of finding these new people to come on
board that a lot of entrepreneurs say
you know what forget it I'm just gonna
go back and do it all myself and that's
not the solution because you can't do it
all yourself you can't change the world
just as a solar person you need to build
a team I'm all excited this comes as a
result of a question from one of my
YouTube viewers loves you guys Allen
who's trying to hire a programmer for
e-commerce website and wanted my advice
let me tell you how to fix the hiring
process okay number one I want you to
rethink your job ad you need to rethink
your job out because your job ad is not
serving you first of all you have to get
a clear understanding of what your
company stands for your value your
one-word and put it in your job
description and make it everywhere okay
if you want to hire nice people that's
got to be right up front and center in
your job ad that you are looking for a
nice person to work with some people are
going to look at that and they're gonna
say this is a stupidest thing ever these
guys want to hire nice people what are
you kidding me you want to hire a nice
programmer how about a programmer who
can get
work done if somebody was nice what are
you nuts that person is not gonna be a
fit for your company right if somebody's
laughing and making fun of your job ad
for you stating what you stand for
they just self eliminated it's perfect
other people are gonna look at that and
say wow they want nice people I'd love
to work with nice people or X you know
whatever your value is you treat people
like family you believe in people you
want to inspire people whatever it is
with that front and center and you're
gonna attract the right kind of people
who are like-minded and love what you
are all about okay as part of rethinking
a job ad you also want to come up with
one long huge description in one
paragraph okay your whole job ad is one
paragraph and buried in the middle
somewhere tiny little section there in
the middle you ask a question I will ask
something like how many Twitter
followers do I have how many subscribers
about having my youtube channel and make
sure that you reply to this job ad with
the answer in the first sentence because
I need somebody who actually read my job
ad imagine that because a lot of people
it's so easy to send an application
right it's so easy I see a job at oh
okay I'm going to apply oh if it's
programming great I'm gonna go apply and
they just change the name in the cover
letter and bam it's up to you what took
them two seconds is now what five
minutes of your time reading through the
cover letter and the resume if a hundred
people do that that's 500 minutes that's
a huge chunk of your day I can't afford
to waste kind of time and it sucks that
for them it's so easy to submit an
application and for me it takes up my
time right it shouldn't be that way so
you have one long huge paragraph as your
job and in the middle you bury that
question and if somebody sends in an
application to me and doesn't in their
first sentence give me that answer I'm
not reading their job I'm not reading
their application right I'm not reading
their resume I'm not reading their cover
letter because you didn't take the time
to actually read my job ad I don't care
if you have the best references the best
Simone yells the best work experience if
you did not actually read my job at all
the way through and look at that
questions and I don't want to I don't
want you working with me it's pretty
simple then you get the other people who
will respond to say you know I'm happy
to to find out your Twitter followers
what's the link to your Twitter page are
you kidding me
go to Twitter type in Evan Carmichael
and you'll find me it is not that hard
it's very simple if you don't have
enough of a work ethic to search that
out on your own then you're definitely
not going to be a fit in my business and
probably not fit in any entrepreneurial
type of company where you got to think
on your feet and be creative I'm not
asking you to step fire outside the box
just tell me how many Twitter followers
I have it's pretty easy to find
okay so we're rethinking our job ad so
that we don't get inundated with people
who who haven't read the ad who are not
qualified and who don't love what our
companies stand for number two no
resumes no cover letters no interviews I
don't accept resumes I don't read cover
letters I don't do job interviews
because they suck time from my life and
they're easy to fake if something that's
easy to fake easy to scam easy to kind
of work your way through then you don't
want to do it right anybody can look
good on paper anybody can have a great
track record and people always fudge
their history right you look at a resume
people always make themselves sound
better than what they actually were and
anybody can ace an interview right if
I'm hiring a programmer like Allan's
asking I have a program to come in I
don't want the guy who is great at
communication and can give me questions
that the answer questions in an
interview on what the guy who's actually
gonna do work you see the resume the
cover letter the the interview have
nothing to do with job performance what
I'm hiring I want somebody to do work
and those things have nothing to do with
work which brings me to number three
give a trial job anybody who answers my
question
the first job ad they get hired on a
trial job find one small thing that
should be accomplished within a set
number of hours hire them for that and
see what they deliver because that's
what it's all about
see here's what most people do you know
you go through that whole process you've
wasted all your time reading those
applications and resumes and calling up
referrals and references and those have
all been you know faked and scammed and
you know people are saying all these
great things about them you know if they
weren't that great right are you really
gonna put a bad reference on your resume
and somebody's gonna call in and say all
the other person really sucked
probably not you've wasted all your time
for that process you've done all the
interviews you've brought your team on
board and wasted all their time as well
then you hire somebody and you know you
know within the first week maybe the
first day if that person is gonna be a
fit or not you know and the ones that
you don't think are affect you you try
to make it work you're trying to find a
way you you coach them you're training
them you know you're trying to you're
trying to find a way to make it work
cause you invested all this time into
them and I'm gonna work you know you're
so frustrated and angry so you think
I've gotta find a way to make this
person work and it just gets worse and
worse and worse and eventually either
they leave you have to fire them and
you're stuck in that same position and
you don't want to go back to go through
all that mess again because the hiring
process is broken better way give them a
trial okay anybody who says you know
anybody who says yes anybody who
answered that question you give them a
trial what I like to do is something
that I think can be accomplished in a
couple hours so I look for a task that
can be done within two hours so if you
if you're creating an e-commerce site
find one task that can be done within
two hours
I give them five hours to do it and if
I'm doing it on oDesk I'll let them
build me for five hours and then I see
do they actually get it done in the two
hours that it should take or do they
milk me for the full five hours because
I don't want the guy who's milking me
for the full five hours that guy's gone
I'll pay him for five hours thank you
very much
I didn't have to spend any time with you
I didn't have to hire you and figure out
that you're gonna be trying to scam me
for the rest of my life in my company
you want the people who are working hard
who get it done within the amount of
time okay next I want to find people who
I can communicate with and have have
good rapport with and who go beyond the
call of duty
yes I'm hiring you to do this one
project but I'm looking for the people
who go above and beyond right and you're
almost always find it you'll find
somebody who will
go way above and beyond and say okay
here's what you hired me to do but then
I also went out did this this this and
this because I thought it might be a fit
if it doesn't work we can always go back
to the original version because you know
that's what hired me to do and here it
is you'll almost always find that person
and often funny enough it's not the
person who looked so great on their
resume write resumes lie resumes don't
tell the truth I've had the people who
are bought on my team who are amazing
often had the worst resumes it would be
hard for them to get a job in a lot of
places most people would pass them over
because they didn't have the experience
and they've been amazing on my team
because they put in the effort because
they try to think of ways to help my
business grow and expand their skills
and use them in a way that contributes
to the business so you're looking for
that and the best way to do it is to
start on the trial start working with
them that's way better time invested
than sitting there in interviews get
them working see what they produce see
if they're fit see if you like the
quality of the work see if they go above
and beyond and delivering something
great for you and then you hire the best
person whoever from that crop of people
who you've hired on your trial you know
who did it they got it done quickly for
you who you have an awesome working
relationship with hire that one person
and you'll have way better results
because you've gone through the whole
system of a non broken hiring process
and a lot of people have struggled on
oDesk and they asked me how do you find
these people and this works not just fro
does this works offline this works with
any process to hire somebody for your
business people ask how do you get it to
work how do you get your team to work
together and how do you find the right
people
I completely flipped around the hiring
process because the current one is
broken and unless you realize that
you're gonna be stuck wasting your time
on the wrong people so to fix your
hiring process
number one rethink your job
advertisement see what you stand for
have one huge ugly paragraph with a
buried question number two no resumes no
cover letters no interviews number three
give a trial job and number four hire
the top performer and believe for those
of you watching you like your video you
want to see more just like it you can
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much for watching and I'll see you soon
if you want the real goods
I share my best advice for entrepreneurs
every week in my newsletter click the
link below to check it out it's free hi
I'm Jason G I sponsor you got a raza
online.com and I want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's the only
newsletter I prioritize and look forward
to period